bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver dans ce nouveau trois théories
comme vous le savez nous sommes en
attente du prochain film des animaux
fantastiques puisque la saga contrat
bien évidemment cinq films c'est un
sujet que vous apprécie beaucoup sur la
chaîne et que j'adore énormément
également l'univers d'harry potter
c'est pourquoi je vous propose de vous
replonger avec moi dans cet univers pour
parler de la saga et des potentiels
théorie quant au futur des films ne
tardons pas je compte sur vous pour
laisser votre meilleur pouces bleus que
les théories commence
[Musique]
à
dans le second opus des animaux
fantastiques
on nous présente la problématique du
pacte de sang dans l'histoire il est dit
qu albus dumbledore et greendale valdes
durant leur jeunesse
on aurait effectué un les empêchant
maintenant de pouvoir s'affronter et de
se blesser mutuellement c'est pourquoi
greendale valdes cherchera à recruter
croyances de son côté pour qu'ils tuent
dumbledore les deux sorciers est en
chacun extrêmement puissant personne
n'arrive à leur cheville
dumbledore représente une énorme menace
pour grindelwald et inversement
l'un doit battre l'autre mais le pacte
les en empêche cependant vous savez tous
comme moi que dans l'histoire d'harry
potter il est dit calbuth et grindelwald
se sont battus en 1945
ce combat se terminera sur une victoire
de dumbledore
mais du coup est ce que cela voudrait
dire que le pacte de sang et détruit un
fait extrêmement intéressant avec green
day waldsee que scénaristiquement il est
considéré comme le grand méchant de la
saga des animaux fantastiques et comme
un antagoniste du passé pour le monde
moderne d'harry potter jusque là tout
est normal
mais contrairement à voldemort ou autres
antagonistes de la saga comme bellatrix
et bien grindelwald ne meurt pas il est
enfermé à vie dans sa propre prison and
urban garde
vous ne trouvez pas ça étrange je sais
que pour beaucoup le pacte de sang sera
détruit c'est d'ailleurs la prochaine
quête d'albus à la fin des animaux
fantastiques 2 mais si ce n'était pas le
cas dans les faits seuls albus
dumbledore peuvent vaincre grindelwald
et inversement les deux sorciers sont
extrêmement puissants et seul un peu
avoir le dessus sur l'autre
c'est pourquoi c'est à albus de vaincre
grindelwald et c'est ce qu'il se passera
néanmoins le pacte de sang est là et il
est impossible de savoir s'il peut être
détruit c'est pourquoi j'aime est un
doute puisque
grindelwald est encore en vie à la fin
du combat de plus nous pouvons nous
interroger quant à la baguette de sureau
d'ong alerte en est le maître
cependant comme il a été démontré dans
harry potter par le biais de voldemort
il ne suffit pas de tuer le propriétaire
de la baguette pour en être le nouveau
détendeur le fait de désarmer la
personne en face suffit simplement albus
étant le nouveau maître de la baguette
de sureau après son combat contre google
earth
il est tout à fait possible que la fin
de la guerre sur le moment où albus des
hommes gais laërt sans le blesser
mortellement ou physiquement ce qui
justifierait le fait que grindelwald
soit encore en vie enfermé à vie dans sa
propre prison et que albu soit le
nouveau propriétaire de la baguette de
sureau d'ailleurs dans l'histoire de
greendale valdes au moment où voldemort
vient lui rendre visite concernant
ladite baguette ce dernier lui dit que
jamais la baguette ne lui obéira et ne
lui révélera pas comment l'obtenir et
maîtriser ses plans pouvoir une
potentielle preuve d'affection des
années plus tard envers albus son ami de
toujours celui qui a certainement
épargné et refuser d'achever grindelwald
au moment de sa défaite
[Musique]
ce qui est pertinent et à la fois
perturbant dans la saga des animaux
fantastiques et que l'on connaît déjà la
fin de la série l'a défait de greendale
valdes face à albi la survie de beaucoup
de personnages dues à leurs actes futurs
dans la saga harry potter et cetera la
saga n'a donc pas réellement pour but
d'instaurer une histoire phénoménal mais
surtout d'enrichir l'univers
l'agrémenter de réponses manquantes par
rapport aux livres ou la saga des huit
films tout ce qui est montré dans les
animaux fantastiques
chaque scène et surtout celle avec les
personnages que nous connaissons déjà ne
sont pas là par hasard et c'est le cas
ici avec nicolas flamel je ne vous
apprends rien l'alchimiste et le
créateur de la pierre philosophale
objets importants du premier film harry
potter et ce vieux personnage est rempli
de mystères
malgré le peu que nous savons lui
nicolas possède énormément d'artefacts
et de savoirs dû à ses 600 ans d'âge
dont notamment ce bouquin avec un phénix
dessus la particularité de ce livre est
qu'il permet de communiquer à distance
avec certainement d'autres possesseurs
d'un livre similaire flamme elle
l'utilisera en urgence après avoir
découvert les plans sombres de
grindelwald à paris pour contacter
quelqu'un si je dis quelqu'un ce n'est
pas par hasard mais parce que nicolas
tombera finalement sur hull ali x la
première à répondre à son appel
les autres photos sont vides signifiant
donc que personne n'ait reçu son appel
là où c'est captivant c'est que eulalie
est une professeur de l'école de
sorcellerie situé dans le nord de
l'amérique il vers morny et par rapport
à la venue de norbert dans la maison de
flamel sous les conseils de dumbledore
qui est lui aussi professeur mais abou
dollar nous pouvons potentiellement
déduire quelque chose ce livre de
contact que détient nicolas flamel
pourrait être relié à chaque école du
monde il y en a 11 par rapport à la
détresse de nicolas au moment de l'
attaque de grindelwald eulalie le pousse
à aller combattre en lui signifiant que
nous croyons en vous ce dialogue est
lourd de sens quand on s'y penche un
petit peu car
laly emploi le pluriel pour affirmer son
soutien à nicolas est également elle le
pousse à aller au combat contre le mal
soit grindelwald
et si les personnages présents dans le
livre faisait partie d'un groupe secret
visant à veiller à ce que la paix règne
d'après les déclarations que nous avons
eues sur la suite de la saga et il est
apparemment dit que laly aurait un rôle
beaucoup plus important dans le prochain
film des animaux fantastiques mais aussi
qu'il pourrait se dérouler
principalement à poudlard ainsi qu'à rio
dé janeiro au brésil
dans ce pays existe également une école
de magie du nom de castello broucqsault
avec pour directrice bénédicte à droite
oh non je ne vous parle pas de la
moutarde
si la théorie se veut exacte et que les
membres du livre forme d'une alliance
contre le mal avec que des professeurs
de chaque école nous pourrions avoir la
venue de ce personnage prochainement
mais surtout comme je vous disais la
saga des animaux fantastiques certes à
enrichir l'univers d'harry potter
nous avons connaissance que l'ordre du
phénix a été fondée par dumbledore dans
les années 1970 le livre de flamme elle
est ornée d'un phénix qui permet
d'ouvrir ce dernier le phénix étant le
symbole de la famille dumbledore et si
albus avait créé cette alliance pour
contrer justement les actes de
grindelwald à travers le monde
après tout pensez vous réellement
calbuth ne fais rien depuis tout ce
temps contre grindelwald
alors que ce dernier cherche à le nuire
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose de particulier avec
norbert ragonneau il est le personnage
principal de la saga des animaux
fantastiques et pourtant c'est une saga
qui traite avant tout de la montée en
puissance de grindelwald et de son futur
combat contre albus dumbledore dans
cette période de l'histoire les
personnages vraiment centraux sont albus
galère tu es croyant ce dû à sa
condition d'obscurs yal et donc son
immense pouvoir voilà
mais alors c'est bizarre que le
personnage principal que nous suivons
soit norbert drago no1 magie zoologiste
qui n'est pas spécialement un très grand
sorcier
peut-être l'avez-vous compris mais si
grindelwald s'est rapproché de croyances
ce n'est pas par hasard
gay laërt est une sorte de voyants et ce
dernier a une vision concernant une
force sombre un obscur yal tuant la
personne qu'il craint le plus au monde
vous vous en doutez cela parle bien
évidemment de croyance tuant de bol d'or
vous le savez aussi le pacte de sang
étant actif grindelwald et dumbledore ne
peuvent pas s'affronter
c'est pourquoi galère cherche à
manipuler croyances pour tuer son rival
sans avoir à le faire mais vous le
remarquez ici ou et norbert dans tout ça
pourquoi on le suit lui à court il sert
et bien c'est là que l'analyse peut être
intéressante
norbert n'est pas un sorcier d'exception
loin de là il est quelqu'un de même très
lambda cependant il est magie zoologiste
et c'est pour ça qu'il intéresse albus
dumbledore
on ne va pas se le cacher albu c'est
quelqu'un qui sait se servir des gens
surtout quand il a un objectif précis je
vous rappelle bien évidemment harry
potter l'horcruxe cachée de voldemort
dont ceux là le bus avait connaissance à
la base et qui s'est donc servi de harry
pour battre voldemort même s'il tenait
beaucoup à lui vu par la suite même
rogge à la base lui affirme qu'il l'a
élevé comme un porc destinés à
l'abattoir de par sa condition de magie
zoologiste albus a fait appel à norbert
pour ça dans son passé et norbert a déjà
réussi à contenir un obscur us dans sa
valise et elle retirée d'une jeune fille
malheureusement décédé par ce dernier
elle est là l'utilité de dragon's au
albus espère de lui pouvoir sauver
croyances et lui extraire l'obscur us un
sauvetage qui s'est malheureusement
soldée de deux échecs
étant donné qu'il n'a pas réussi à le
sauver dans les deux premiers films
il est donc possible que toute
l'intrigué de norbert repose là-dessus
scénaristiquement il est le soldat entre
guillemets d'albus dandy que croyance et
le soldat de gueule hertz c'est comme
une sorte de deux contre deux plus on
avance dans la série et plus
potentiellement l'histoire se tournera
donc vers albus et geel hertz est
cependant dommage que le rôle de norbert
s'arrête juste à sauver croyances mais
qui sait il est possible que son rôle se
développe encore plus mais à cause de la
condition d'obscurs yal il est fort à
parier que croyance mourra dans les
films à venir
merci du fond du coeur d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère sincèrement qu'elle
vous aura plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à laisser votre meilleur pouces bleu
un petit commentaire et surtout à vous
abonner à cette chaîne pour toujours
plus de théorie sur la pop culture
vous pouvez également me suivre sur
instagram et twitter ou me soutenir
financièrement via your type
j'ai très hâte de reparler d'harry
potter et des animaux fantastiques avec
vous que le lay alors soit avec vous
bien évidemment aller c'est et arcoroc
et ciao tout le monde
[Musique]